nadie sabe si vladimir putin planea
invadir ucrania pero una cosa es cierta
ha desplegado más de 100.000 soldados en
la frontera y exige que ucraniano se una
a la otan acciones que han impulsado una
rápida respuesta diplomática sobre la
crisis eeuu y reino unido- sopesan se
enviará más soldados para ayudar a la
otan y preparan sanciones generalizadas
contra los oligarcas si moscú invade
también el consejo de seguridad de la
onu celebró una reunión pública sobre el
tema la situación a la que nos
enfrentamos en europa es urgente y
peligrosa y lo que está en juego para
ucrania y para todos los estados
miembros de la onu no podría ser mayor
las acciones de rusia golpean el corazón
mismo de la carta de la onu se trata de
una amenaza a la paz ya la seguridad tan
clara y consecuente como cualquiera
pueda imaginar en un agrio intercambio
el embajador ruso contraatacó
insistiendo que estos temores son
infundados
esta es la búsqueda de nuestros colegas
estadounidenses para usar la histeria
que gira en torno a su propia narrativa
sobre la supuesta agresión rusa
inminente pero en la que quizás sea la
discusión más pública y diplomática de
la crisis hasta la fecha no sé ninguna
resolución ni se espera que pase
rusia es un miembro permanente y junto
con su aliado china no va a permitir que
se apruebe nada ambos tienen veto otra
cosa que es importante recordar en el
tipo de logística diplomática de todo
esto es que rusia asume la presidencia
del consejo de seguridad el primero de
febrero
eeuu dijo que la reunión de dos horas
fue no obstante una importante muestra
de determinación mientras rusia dice que
no se amedrentará ante las amenazas de
sanciones de eeuu